hi everybody I will not talk about any
of the pieces of work you see on the
screen today I'm gonna talk about
something that is just starting it's
it's it's often a temptation to talk
about things that you've been are
perfect than out in the world and
whereas now that we're trying to grapple
with a problem I'd like to share that
with you and I'm gonna grab a lot of you
during the breaks to help us crack this
problem the problem like most
conversations started in a pub in London
with this man who is the chief executive
of a wonderful charity called malaria no
more in the United Kingdom and over a
course of a few too many pints I learned
a bunch of things I learned first of all
that the equivalent of the population of
a city like Seattle or Baltimore or
Washington DC or Denver or Nashville
dies every year from malaria in Africa
and if that's not tragic enough the vast
majority of those 86% of those are
children under the age of five and
what's really amazing about this to me
is that these stats are a success story
in the past ten years deaths from
malaria have dropped by 42% we've moved
from a kid dying every 30 seconds to a
kid down every minute but I'm not being
flippant about our being a success story
we have an opportunity in our lifetime
to eradicate deaths from malaria it's
been done before it's been done in North
America it's been done in Europe but we
are at that critical stage that they
will tell you they call the last mile
and the last mile is the point where you
feel like you're about to eradicate you
lose kind of the focus on it and the
parasite returns with a vengeance and
the curve moves once again in the other
direction and while you need to maintain
the funding and the programs and the
policy this is the point in the struggle
where you have to now engage the end
users you have to engage people and
really make this something that they
become a part of eradicated and when I
hear that my brain just
goes well that's a creative challenge
how do you get individuals to engage
with something that is negative and and
that they don't want to talk about how
do you make this something that they get
involved in them I have real real
understanding of that challenge because
I grew up in rural West Africa I'm the
cute guy to the left of the teacher time
hasn't been good to me and every year
twice a year at least I got malaria I
come from a middle-class educated family
so I was always gonna get the fluids I
was always gonna get the meds so I was
never at the risk of death but it often
felt like it I mean malaria I don't know
if anybody's anybody here had malaria so
we have somebody there grab him if your
next thing
malaria makes the flu feel like a paper
cut it's it's it's it's completely
debilitating and growing up in an ER in
a village of really just subsistence
farmers I have so many memories of
little boxes being lowered into the wet
earth and trying to make sense of how
the person lying dead in that was
playing football with us just a week ago
those are not things people want to
engage with in communities and so when I
think about some of the things that
we've been able to do out with Orleans
in my time whether it's red which really
takes this thing about AIDS and turns
into something actually that we can tell
a story about that we can be positive
about that we can create some energy
around this and take that horrible thing
but actually put a really positive spin
that engages many people and certainly
brings the energy and power of lots of
organizations together to make something
happen
I kind of see okay there is a way you
can begin to do something around this or
if I think about little Sun which is a
word development partners with the
artist Oliver Eliassen on this which
literally puts the electricity the power
of light that means that a fact that a
kid can study at night and that families
can stay up a bit later and discuss
their day which has an amazing social
impact in their lives and and actually
that the way you you do that is by
empowering local communities to be at
the heart of how they solve that problem
which is a huge one 1.6 billion people
around the world don't have access to
safe or reliable electricity and the
options the hacks they put together can
be incredibly dangerous to them and
expensive over a period of time but what
I love about little son which is this
thing that has such utility at the point
of need
is also an object of desire in the
Western world so you kind of get this
this balance between both sides my
ten-year-old daughter who lives an
affluent enough life in central London
doesn't go anywhere without her little
son so those two things gave me a hint
that actually that this malaria thing
that I'd always thought about as a
problem you don't ever want to talk
about because it's just darkness and you
see the success over the past ten years
you think to yourself we can do
something about this we can create
something really positive that makes a
big difference and with the help of the
guys from malaria no more in the past
six weeks we've started exploring a
solution which I'd like to share with
you today we simplify our task as to pit
creativity against malaria and we call
the idea code n encode M the idea behind
code M is a series of products that have
a utility at the point of need they help
people beat give people the power in
their own hands to beat malaria but
they're also objects of desire out in
the Western world and so they contribute
to solving the problem but actually just
because they are such attractive and
wonderful things they create an
awareness of the problem and that key
that will keep the pressure up on the
funding community on the government's on
the NGOs to keep working on this problem
until we've completely eradicated it and
we we're designing a system around three
key groups the first group will call
creatives these are the people that were
asking to help us really think
differently about that point of need and
how we solve the problem we're talking
about we're talking to retailers to say
certainly in the West but actually we
one of the retailers is already on board
is a company called Junior Jimmy ng
which is the largest e-commerce site in
Africa's largest economy in Nigeria so
they're on board because we need to be
able to get these things out to market
and then the final group is experts
because we need people who can actually
help us really identify and define the
problem malaria no more have been fine
has to get that for us but also to
validate that the things were created
actually do will contribute to solve
that problem so those are the three
groups we've put together and that
creates a system for us and in the past
six weeks we've done a few things to
test this which I'd love to share with
you today two weeks ago we brought a
bunch of what we will call the group
creatives and so it was people from the
Science Museum in London people from the
Royal College of Art a innovation
consultancy based out in Kenya called
balloon Kenya and a few other people and
I've just got um about a minute and a
bit of video that just captures that day
and the soundtrack you're hearing over
this where we set them a brief and I'll
tell you what the brief is in a second
where we set them a brief is also came
also out of that day but what we said to
them is everything you create has to fit
four boxes first of all you have to
create something that solves a problem
at the point of need but could also be
an attractive thing that somebody will
want to buy out in the West we said it
has to be something I choose to use not
something I have to use so make it
playful make it desirable so I actually
choose it it has to fit into the malaria
economy so these have to be affordable
things that anybody can buy and because
again 86 percent of the people who die
from malaria are children if we can
educate the current under-fives around
malaria we will eradicate this disease
in our lifetime and then the guys at
malaria no more helped us even make that
a very specific brief for these people
that they spend today looking at which
is create a product for a child to
protect them from being bitten by
mosquitoes at night so here's a minute
of of what the guys did together for a
day
some very specific ideas came out of it
I won't spend much time talking about
them there was the music that you just
heard there was some lyrics to that but
segorita kept saying smack and crack and
you can't put it on something that
targets five-year-olds we had lots of
really practical ideas so there's this
series this family of objects including
the evil miss Monique but also something
that soaks up the liquid around the
house which is where mosquitoes breed a
little personalized spray can something
that plays with your nets and the doctor
which is where you can keep your
treatment so things are again that
engage children around stuff lots of
ideas from Nets that pull up to nets
that pop up to nets that become
educational so that the kid really
enjoys using them two nets that you
would use outdoors and the in the hot
months where you really want to sleep on
the roofs but you can't have your bed
and your and your bed net over there so
lots of really practical ideas that gave
us a sense that this is doable two other
things to talk about which is the other
two groups and here it's really work in
progress as I said the the e-commerce
site Jimmy are on board what we're
trying to make sure that we create is a
system that retailers kind of learning
from what we did on red a system that
retailers can adopt it starts with the
EM but that M turns into of course a
nets because that becomes almost the
icon of malaria eradication but you can
personalize it you can bring the energy
and the different ideas that are around
that and when you have a system like
that then you get to this point where
people can begin to create lots of
variations that become much more
honorable for each individual retailer
to customizer and create their own
patterns and then the final people to
talk about is the experts and with
experts we've got the learning platform
Kahoot on board and what they are going
to do is they're gonna host a place
where experts can put four kinds of
information that creative people are
going to need to design around this the
basic science a lot around malaria
because you need to understand some
basics before you get involved in this
the issues with manufacturing and
distributing particularly lots of stuff
we've learnt from what people with Nets
have done the research on behavior and
this is where there's a big gap how do
people behave and we know the technical
solutions but how can we create things
that work
malaria economy and what are some of the
cultural platforms that NGOs sometimes
miss that we can really begin to adopt
to get these products into the hands of
the people who we need to make this
change with so that's kind of it the
minute I finish this talk I'm gonna
click a magic button somewhere and a
website is gonna go alive it's gonna be
WWE code m-net netiquette and and and
we're really asking people to sign up
and tell us how they can help and it is
again around those three areas creatives
retailers and experts and that's where I
haven't asked for you today we've got a
date and just like the little make day
we had in the office two weeks ago we're
really envisioning hundreds of these
happening around the world and between
now and then we're gonna create kits
that allow creative people anywhere to
download a bunch of challenges and spend
the day helping us solve this problem so
we again I'm inviting you all to please
become partners of this as we go through
this we already beginning to create
collect partners here are some of the
creative partners that are on board but
we have a whole wish list of partners we
want to get on board
there are retail partners on board
already but we have a whole list of
retail partners we want to get on board
we've got these experts a whole bunch of
other experts that we want to get on the
board so I'm really asking the
collective anybody who thinks that this
is a problem that they will want to get
involved in to help us kind of find
these partners so that's called M and I
just want to kind of maybe summarize
with a slightly different point it's
really easy to think about this kind of
work when you when the problem is so
articulate and when you come from Africa
our problems in Africa are very
articulate when you're thinking about
transportation or electricity or just
the normal everyday life that people
live but we're beginning to really
understand in our work that when we
attack the problems that matter to
people when we get people together
that's actually more important than
actually thinking about what the brand
we're trying to create is and when that
problem is poverty in a more social
sense or an organization that's facing
slower growth or an organization who's
confusing its marketplace we find that
when you get many people together across
the problems that matter you create a
great brand by default but actually
being really focused on the problems
that matter to us all is so much more
important thank you very much